une femme à la tête du conseil
départemental du haut rhin c'est une
première légitime kert a été ce matin en
séance plénière elle succède ainsi à
eric straumann désormais député ce
dernier avait démissionné suite à la loi
sur le cumul des mandats
les trois priorités sont l'emploi parce
que malheureusement le chômage les
chiffres du chômage ne sont pas beaux en
alsace ensuite nous avons la jeunesse
qui est vraiment une priorité
vous savez que nous avons la compétence
décollage alors certes il ya les
investissements mais je souhaite aussi
faire entrer plus la culture
l'engagement et la citoyenneté et la
troisième priorité c'est l'alsace voilà
ce sont les trois grands chantiers qui
s'ouvrent demande devant moi dès cet
après midi